this is Australia
no sugar look at that
[Music]
no sugar look at that
another one no sugar are they making us
start there huh
that tastes so good flaxseeds
[Music]
[Music]
so these are all made with no sugar but
you got natural sugars from the we got
peaches in here I think you got some
raisins there no blue berries there
peach real food air with you Mike
[Music]
even best team that does everything
sellout heavy yeah we start
fella
sorry bro good you know I've been trying
to get ahold of you and you're so
difficult I was going to invite you to
this conference but I spoke to shake up
the rain green yeah and he said he
didn't know if you were here on it yeah
but hum de l'eau you're here but I
invited him to come down he spoke we're
supposed to meet up next week next week
yeah yeah next week yeah but all
conferences do you think for the
conference we're talking about the the
ratio actually of women to men that are
accepting Islam it's like as I said it's
like eight eight women accept Islam for
every single male eight women for every
one male but I thought that Islam
oppresses women yeah well why would they
be excited not like that I mean it's
really it's really fascinating and this
is this is a phenomenon that I saw like
across the Europe I mean when I spoke to
the brothers in Austria in Germany they
all said like the same but a lot of
women are except except Enix LA and not
so much demand whose fortunately put on
the hijab Wow no no one I mean no one
forcing low on the hijab no this is out
their own free choice I mean it's very
did this is a very interesting question
because you know in Slovenia women Bob
Austin little girls women are not
usually covered so when they cover that
there's basically I mean there they are
move how can you say it scrutinized by
by their own communities why are you
wearing the controller yeah and so on I
mean it's really a matter of how do you
say free choice it's not yeah so these
women are on their own
looking into the evidence of Islam yes
they're looking for purpose of life they
find it in Islam and they accept an egg
they go ahead and they start to practice
it implement it with no coercion huh
yeah no no covers no covers isn't that
from Newcastle from north Oh what's the
difference here now
Newcastle how's that Newcastle is the
best city in the UK and is right at the
top near Scotland
and it's a much better place - so we got
era in the house in Bosnia of course
what's up with that huh I'm doing the
down
[Music]
[Music]
all
my job today is to introduce the
conference how do you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's food is nobody sent them the
beans will to the creators
that's Islam so then it keeps going you
have today paradise in the next life do
you know about the book of meals yeah I
also know they were Unitarian Christian
yeah yeah so our ancestors were actually
Christian true monotheists you know
Scott went out when the aslam came it
fit like a glove
you know they said you know I had a lot
to say there's nothing worthy worshipped
except Allah and they accepted Islam
yeah so any Christians watching they can
say wow these were actually their
answers for Christian and many people
because they struggle they also had some
similar practices to our to us muslims
for example to use to do is to pray a
lot and so on and many questions when
you talk to him like how was your
experience in Dawa people really don't
understand and they put their mind on
hold when it comes to Trinity so they
have a hard time struggling with it but
now these Unitarians they were like just
worship God alone yeah right how was
your experience when you deal with
Christians from Sylvania I mean to be
quite honest if you look like for the
past 20 years there's been an uprising
of atheism in our country it's like 65
percent of people oh no it's 54 percent
of people say in the statistics that
that what did they say that they that
they don't that the religion does not
mean anything to them in their lives or
God
yes I knew religion the statistics from
the 90s when the war you know break
break it up in Boston there was like 90%
of Christians and now you have like more
more or less less than 50% more country
what do you think's the cause of that
well I don't know if you knew it but
Slovenia is one of the top countries in
suicide rate in Europe in the world it's
has this highest level more people going
to atheism but now what's happy at the
same time more suicide it's similar to
Scandinavian countries so yeah one of
the highest levels of suicide yeah
yes yes it's like I mean it's like top 5
countries in the world but people who
have it now this is a fact now people
who have faked having lived for a higher
purpose live for the crater inner peace
inner peace you don't see those rates of
suicide no no no basically I mean when
you look at the Muslim countries you
don't see anything yeah I mean the
suicide rate is almost non-existent what
do you think causes people to go towards
atheism there I I would say materialism
and the media you know because they they
watch all of these Marvel movies and
basically it's like demigods
if you think about it it's like
polytheism all over again
yeah right for example it's the media
mostly because for example in Slovenia
the media is most is mostly left you
know left-wing and India days they try
to present religion or something
backwards or something you know
that should be you know that that should
have been left in the past you know so I
think the dis is and also to be quite
frank it's also the church scandals
because we had a lot of yeah to be quite
honest like you guys I read an article
the other day that a lot of these
churches in in USA are like you know
people are coming out most of these
people they haven't given Islamic shot
yeah yeah and this is this is our
responsibility and we are we are lacking
in this department
hey but if so much this year in genuine
and they give it Salameh shot what do
you think what happen we see it happen
yeah yeah I mean as I said I mean I did
it myself I mean I I talk to people
every time I get the opportunity I talk
about this time and many of them are
shocked you know for example that we
believe in Jesus that you cannot be a
Muslim if you do not believe in Jesus I
mean this is like one of the pillars of
our of our faith so it's basically it's
educating the masses yeah
educating Salama shot you've tried
everything else yeah yes right literally
people try everything else we'll do all
sorts of crazy things
why not gonna shut this llama shot huh